اوراق اكاديميه ملفقه مليئه ببيانات مزيفه
تجتاح منصات تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي وتعرض
حياتنا للخطر طفله مدمره دفعت باحثين في
المانيا استخدموا تقنيات جديده للتحذير من
الاحتيال العلمي حيث كشفت الدراسه ان
واحده من كل خمس مقالات اكاديميه منشوره
في المجلات قد تحتوي على بيانات غير دقيقه
صحيفه
تنتجها مصانع الاوراق البحثيه وهي منظمات
تنتج وتبيعه مقالات واوراقا اكاديميه تم
التلاعب بها للباحثين لتعزيز حياتهم
المهنيه
الدراسه خلصت ايضا الى ان غالبيه الابحاث
المزيفه تاتي من الصين حيث تطلب بعض
المستشفيات والسلطات الصحيه من الاطباء ان
يعدوا اوراقا اكاديميه بحثيه بشكل مستمر
عدد الاوراق المزيفه في الطب الحيوي ارتفع
من 16% في عام 2010 الى 20% في عام 2020
مع زياده كبيره في مجال علم الاعصاب
مقارنه بالطب السريري وفق الدراسه مع
التقدم التكنولوجي ومزودي البرمجيات ظهرت
تكاؤل الاصطناعي بشكل روتيني لكن مع زياده
فوائد انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي تزداد
المخاطر المصاحبه لهذه الادوات اولى هذه
المخاطر تكمن في الافتقار الى امكانيه
تتبع تنفيذ الذكاء الاصطناعي الى جانب
ادخال التحيز في خوارزميات صنع القرار
يضاف الى هذه المخاطر ايضا ان الخصوصيه
الشخصيه ستصبح حمايتها اكثر صعوبه خصوصا
عند حدوث تسرب للبيانات او انتهاكات
مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي كبيره لكن استخدام
هذه الادوات ونموها باتا امرا حتميا ايضا
مع زياده تقدم التكنولوجيا وانتشارها اياد
حمود العربيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات